welcome to this video or the wolves and
all of Walden yeah come on play move
here we go and this time I'll be quicker
promise sort of from Queens Indian wow
that that's very aggressive what's right
setup okay maybe prepare for a five that
I can go be 50 now he's sacrificing upon
shaking in my boots here the guy is
doing nothing and then he's sacrificing
a pawn on the queenside that's funny I
just I'll just play quickly now never
mind the position okay Bishop a six and
d5 will be my next move yeah and trying
to play for d5 go for cheap tricks the
stuff that and now look I'm going for a
cheap trick and I win quickly this is
what i need to do not those long end
games and whatnot yeah just go for very
simple stuff and take pieces in 19
seconds sometimes it works yeah maybe
this is the recipe for success even with
the with commentary here yeah play very
simple stuff play it quickly hope for
the best yeah certainly better than
thinking about what move was the most
precise when you have three good ones
okay that was a very quick video but
yeah i'm going to post it anyway i hope
you enjoyed it added laughs at least
thanks for watching